okay so one division ends this week and
that means i'm not only gonna have to
find something else to milk
i'm also gonna feel the grief over
losing this show
however what is grief if not simply love
persevering
so i thought we'd do this one last time
and go through our predictions and
theories before we get the answers that
we've been waiting for
over the last eight weeks our last two
big predictions were pretty close to
what we ended up getting
so hopefully we get the hat trick and
can claim that we got at least three fan
theories right
out of nine thousand now this is your
first time here
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who has no
problem bringing his soulmate online
now let's get into the video okay so
first off i want to discuss something
that feels like it's fell by the wayside
in recent episodes
that is the identity of monica's
engineer teased all the way back in
episode 5
we've gone back and forth over whether
it's reed richards
blue marvel simon williams or mephisto
episode 7
seems like it might have given us some
answers but at the same time
it also didn't during the entry monica
met with major goodness
and though some people think that this
is just a contact delivering the goods
i actually think that this was the
engineer now why
is this well in the build up to it
monica says she's meeting her guy over
the ridge
and thus they have to be at this
location upon greeting one another
this scene also happens
nice to meet you thank you so much for
coming
my mother would appreciate your loyalty
she's not the only one we're loyal to
captain
now i might be mistaken but it sounds
like goodness is loyal to both the
rambos
and her getting thanked for it does make
me think that she's the person monica
was texting
i don't feel like we have enough time in
the last episode to fully introduce a
new character that fans will connect
with
and therefore i think that this person
is actually a scroll
namely talos's daughter who we were
first introduced to
in captain marvel monika already of
course has a friendship with her
and the scrolls definitely owe the
rambos for their actions in that film
scrolls are also highly advanced
technology wise and they had the
ability to go interstellar so it makes
sense that the daughter could also be an
aerospace engineer
used to creating ships and vehicles
tiona paris has said that their identity
is something special
and therefore think that there's more to
goodness than meets the eye now speaking
of cameos and reveals
a lot of people are still speculating
that there's a big one coming down the
line
due to comments made by paul bettany
after the evan peters won the actor
stated that
in the future we'd see someone who he'd
wanted to work with since he was a boy
and that he had quote unquote
extraordinary chemistry with
after the double vision reveal i think
people were split with some of us saying
that this is what he was talking about
the whole time
and that it was actually just a troll
there's still people in the camp that
someone bigger is coming
but after i tell you the next video
don't hold your breath
now when asked about what bettany meant
director matt shachman recently said
i'm gonna let paul bettany answer that
he dug himself this whole
he can get out of it so i wouldn't bet
any
money that he's working with al pacino
or everyone's favorite actor
kevin bacon now saying that i do still
think that doctor strange is coming as
benedict not only popped up on the zoom
call when they were promoting the show
but it kind of breaks the universe if
their character doesn't appear
doctor strange is someone who's in
charge of protecting our reality
douchebag and with this series breaking
that to the point people are living in
pleasantville i feel like he has to get
involved
if he sits this one out then it raises a
lot of questions
and thus i think he will come in at the
last second to not only help take down
agatha and the hex
but also to stop wonder i've been
talking to youtubers superhero nexus
about how we think the show will end
and we both agree that it will pull from
house of m which culminates in strange
going to stop wonder himself
now it is possible that strange is also
going to bring someone across from the
fox universe with him
and that could be cody smith mcphee aka
nightcrawler
in a recent discussion john rocker made
the following statement
when discussing one division i'm gonna
reveal something here really quick and
i'm gonna walk the line
if i can on this a few weeks ago i
interviewed cody smith mcphee
there are some things he said in our
interview that his agent publicist
asked me to go back and edit out now i
understand why
so that's all i'm gonna say there was
something that i asked him about
something
and we got into a discussion about
comparing certain directors he's worked
with
i won't reveal who they are they asked
me to cut that out
but then he reveals something else about
the character he has played
i thought it was a fun thing to say
because in my mind no way did i think
something was going to happen
and who knows maybe that's why they
asked me to edit our responses to that
question
so just leave it there i don't know
what's happening but we might not be
done
so there is potential that he could show
up in the series but we don't know for
definite yet
and we don't know we don't really know
anything of that statement but
i'm just saying it now just in case this
series actually has
a lot on its plate as it's not only
setting up doctor strange too
but it's also going to be laying the
groundwork for ms marvel spider-man 3
and of course captain marvel 2. honestly
i think it would be pretty hilarious if
brielle austin was the cameo at the end
just because all the videos we'd get
saying it's a disgrace
no but monica is clearly going to be
getting the moniker photon or spectrum
and she will likely go on to be a hero
in that film
in regards to spider-man no way home i
actually think that agatha might be a
person who ties into it in some form
throughout the series she's joked about
biting kids
and throughout folklore it's often been
thought that witches eat children
this stems from hansel and gretel but it
could also be where agatha draws her
power from
i do think that she will be defeated in
the finale but rather than dying
i think that she will make her escape
and then pop up in other marvel
properties
the missing children posters that were
seen behind the scenes in no way home
could tie back to her and who knows it
may be revealed that she's been
kidnapping kids around the planet
now as for her plan it is possible that
this ties back to her husband ralph
who as of now we still haven't seen
though the book in her basement may be
the darkhold
there is another possibility that it's
the necronomicon
that originates from the 1950s when
marvel was going under the name atlas
this horror story actually featured a
man known as ralph
who ended up becoming trapped in the
book itself and perhaps
agatha's plan is to try and learn how
wonder is so powerful
so that she can free him now as for how
the group will defeat her
i think that this was set up in episode
8 and that we will see runes placed
about the hex which will stop agatha
from being able to cast spells
these were pretty sloppily explained in
my opinion and it felt like a chekhov's
gun scenario that was the key to
defeating witches in general
so i think it's pretty obvious they're
gonna be used here
now what is funny is i've been watching
a lot of old mcu films this week in
order to see if there's any layered
easter eggs
and we've seen far from home that mr
dell has an obsession with witches and
witchcraft
it could be possible that this interest
is spurned on by the events of one
division
but that might just be a reach but but
the guy did like witches for some reason
now after i get the fleas i feel like
we're gonna get the vision versus vision
showdown
shout outs to pop culture minefield for
messaging me and saying that they think
just in the same way that several
versions of monica mulder together as
she passed through the hecks
but the consciousness of vision will be
molded in with his true body
now this actually has precedent in the
comics and it definitely could be the
way that the character lives on
you rock stars have just posted a big
breakdown on this
and during the video they talk about how
visions consciousness was actually
merged with another version of himself
from a different dimension this is
definitely a way that the character
could live on
but i still don't think he will i'm
gonna tell you why
right now okay so the entire show is
about grief and how wonder was driven to
create this reality
because she simply couldn't accept the
loss that she's been subjected to
because of this she's brought her
husband back to life her brother in some
form
and created a family that's not too
dissimilar from the one that she had
when she was younger
every time someone has tried to reveal
the truth to her she's either rolled the
credits
rewound time or tried to shut them up
like me
when people say mephisto isn't sparky
thus i feel like the general theme of
the show is about acceptance
and learning to move on in the face of
grief wanda's entire journey throughout
the show has been her realizing that she
simply can't magic her problems away
and that though it's devastating losing
someone it doesn't mean that we won't
eventually be able to accept what's
happened
the seven stages of grief are typically
defined as denial pain
guilt anger depression reconstruction
and lastly acceptance wonder has gone
through most of these stages throughout
the show
and i feel like it's robbing the
character of this development if vision
simply comes back to life
instead i think he will die during the
fight and that the hex will start to
collapse after this devastating blow to
wander once more
quicksilver will then step in and rescue
the town folk from being sucked into the
abyss of wonder's grief
but rather than imploding she will
finally accept that vision's gone
and instead look to the future that she
now has with her children
vision isn't listed as being in doctor
strange too and now that could change
i think his name not appearing in the
cast list whilst elizabeth olsons does
highlights who's gonna live and who's
gonna die teona paris has said that the
ending of the season is very depressing
so yay more good things to look forward
to for 2021
however there is another possibility and
in the recently released shots of
episode 9 we see the family standing
ready for a fight
similar something from the incredibles
however vision's face is free of the
markings that he typically has
and other than looking like he's smeared
in beetroot juice
he does seem like a human it could be
possible that white vision is programmed
to destroy anything with a vibranium
signature
and this might be why wanda turns him
into a more human form
however in doing so she might make him a
full man too that doesn't possess
powers and this could be why he isn't
present in any of the upcoming films
throughout vision's life and even in the
hex we've seen as he's been someone that
doesn't have any real choice of his own
and that he's always trying to carry out
another person's agenda
during the show he's gained some
autonomy and gone looking for answers
himself
and this may be why he's not in doctor
strange too perhaps at the end of the
season he makes the decision to leave
wonder instead of continuing to live as
somewhat of a slave
and the show could culminate with him
becoming his own man
there's also the question of what's
going to happen to evan peters
and when discussing his role going
forward shakman did say
i think there's a strong possibility you
might get a little more of evan peters
coming up
but how that plays out i wouldn't want
to say so it seems like he will be
appearing in the mcu going ahead
and i really hope that he remains his
quicksilver though
due to agatha's comments it does look
unlikely i feel like it's a missed
opportunity though if they don't have
him as the one from the fox universe
and it's a bit disappointing if he's
simply there for a meta joke
having rewatched episode 7 numerous
times i feel like this snooper is gonna
snoop comment was him referring to how
he was also going around agatha's house
investigating
i doubt he will be possessed if he is
though vision can snap him out of it
pretty fast
and therefore i think for episode nine
he's pretty much gonna be a good guy
shakman also said that he feels like
some fans will be disappointed by the
finale
but we have to remember that this isn't
the end of the character ox
and that things can still happen going
forward into phase four and five
i feel like the skull at which tees
won't come to fruition until doctor
strange two at the earliest
and as long as they lay the groundwork i
trust marvel to pay things off down the
line
now there are some spoilers in the rest
of the video so if you don't want
anything ruined for definite then i
recommend that you turn off now
also if you're enjoying the theory so
far then please hit the thumbs up button
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss our coverage of the finale
okay so as for the kids it looks
extremely likely that the twins will
become permanent fixtures in the mcu
both actors who play tommy and billy put
posts on their instagrams that had them
about a hundred meters apart in london
during november 2020 this was at the
time that dr strange was being filmed in
the city and as it seems pretty much a
certainty
that they'll be in the movie if this is
the case and that means they won't age
up at the end of the show
and that they will survive past the
collapse of the hex i think that wonder
will focus her powers in the finale to
keep them alive
and from there she'll go on the run with
the kids from here doctor strange will
attempt to track her down
and that will be the main jumping off
point of the film
as for the end of the series i actually
think that we will get a tease towards a
big bad
and that will rejoin agatha meeting
someone shady similar the ending of the
avengers
there are rumors that nightmare is gonna
be a villain in the multiverse of
madness
and it's difficult to ignore all the
dream word play that's been laced
throughout the show
i feel like just in the same way that
thanos was set up that the disney plus
shows and movies will have their own
overarching villains that are debuted
early on
and then slowly will build up towards
them marvel know through thanos that
this formula works well
and therefore it just makes a lot of
sense to have them do this again
now that's pretty much my main theories
and obviously i'd love to hear yours so
make sure you comment below and let me
know
as thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
on the 31st of march in which we're
giving away three copies of a marvel 4k
boxer of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the predictions the winners
of last month's competition are on
screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of episode 8 which
will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointed out all the
cool little easter eggs in it
so definitely give it a watch after this
that other way thank you for sitting
through the video
i've been paul and i see you next time
take care
peace